all right I feel like talking Doctor Who
a little bit more I've done my countdown
of my favourite doctors going up through
number 11 I counted down the Companions
of the modern era now I feel like
talking villains now like with my
campaigns list I am gonna be confining
myself to the modern era just so this
thing doesn't get ridiculously long and
because of the glut of fantastic
villains and monsters that this show has
given us I've actually got to break this
into parts and right now I'm going to
talk one time villa so these are
villains who have appeared in only one
story and to be clear two partners count
as one story they've only been in one
story in the modern era and they have
not returned now some of them may return
and in fact a lot of them I would like
to see return but so far they happen so
here is my count on of the top ten one
time
Doctor Who villains number 10 the
Minotaur as seen in the episode the god
complex this villain we don't actually
learn all that much about them but this
is just a creature and a monster that is
perfectly utilized between the hotel
serving as the labyrinth and just
changing up all the time and the
creature itself being really kind of an
unwilling villain it doesn't want to be
consuming these people but it can't help
itself it's instinctive when you put its
food in front of it it's going to eat
and that's what it's doing even though
it would just as soon lay down and die I
find that layer of complexity really
interesting I like what it brought out
of the characters both the ones who
survived and the ones who didn't there'd
be no point in ever bringing this guy
back but for his use in his appearance
really masterfully done number 9 house
this is a villain that should not work
it's a sentient planet comet trash ball
that really has no physical presence
it's just a voice and a green light and
that's it there's no way that that
should be an effective villain but man
is it ever between the way that he's
written and the way that Michael Sheen
delivered that vocal performance he gave
menace and he gave
this great sense of arrogance he just
delivered so much punch with just a
voice and what he put those characters
through just because he could because he
wanted to be entertaining because he
wanted the energy of the TARDIS and it's
actually a really fun contrast in terms
of how that character is handled and how
interest is done the essence of the
TARDIS something that is normally
completely intangible it's just a sense
we get from this machine put into a
physical body and given your life and
physical action whereas the villain you
normally you need that physical
intimidation you need to see it in its
eyes and you need to get that sense for
a villain a proper Menace but they don't
have that it's completely in Kippur eeeh
yet it works number eight
Davros now I expect him to come back I
would be stunned if he never comes back
but he hasn't yet so I have to put him
on the one timers list what is there to
say about Davros that hasn't been said
already creator of the Daleks he has
this wonderful sense of Dalek Ness about
him between the way his voice is and
that that sort of glow of the eye up
here in the in the wheelchair thing that
he's stuck in yet he's still distinctly
different he's got this maniacal sense
to him he's not quite as single-minded
he's not as trapped in one way of
thinking as the Daleks are which in a
way makes him actually more dangerous
than the Daleks
he is a nihilistic villain at his
complete essence for him absolute
measure of his power is his ability to
obliterate everything he's capable of it
he's willing to do it he's got his
history with the doctor as well and
while I can't really count his
appearances in the classic era towards
his ranking on this list you feel the
weight of their history even if this is
the only episode you've ever seen them
in number 7 the Vashta Nerada are you
afraid of the dark well you will be by
the time you're done with that's two
parter shadows that eat you I mean what
a great concept and again like so many
of these things just really well
visually realize cuz it could have been
really cheesy could have been this
stupid cheesy animated shadow that just
lashed out you know it's a simple thing
there's two shadows
and then you're gone and then that swarm
mentality that says as they start to get
to be able to communicate and credit
where credit's dude the doctor does not
defeat them all he does is convince them
not to kill him that day that's the best
he can manage with this stuff it's fear
of the dark it is true classic at our
core fear that we've all had at some
point in our life it's the perfect thing
to tap into a doctor who's really good
at that
number six mr. Finch and the krillitanes
I'll admit I'm really biased on this one
and it's largely because I love anthony
Stewart head I think he is amazing and
he is really the reason that they rank
so high and that I want him specifically
to come back the guerrilla takes as this
concept are kind of cool also the idea
that they evolved continuously and they
adapt features from places that they
conquer which means if they ever do come
back they don't have to look like the
CGI bad things they look before they can
be completely redesigned but still be
those same villains but if they ever
come back
we need anthony Stewart head because
just watch the scene where he faces off
with David Tennant near that pool he
just has this sense of gravitas and
weight to the words that he's saying
that even though they're just talking
politely at that you just you get this
feeling that the doctor really is
talking to somebody who could stand up
to him and it has nothing to do with
physical power any any show of actual
intelligence any sense of ruthlessness
you just get this sense of weight to his
words then and you just leaves you
thinking oh we're in trouble and then
when he gets ticked off and he's he's
got that scowl it's he's great on screen
I just I would love to get him back I
think we could think about it when that
of oil explodes on all the other
krillitanes they're screaming yeah being
burned he's just standing there yes
there was a big explosion after that but
he was obviously a not as affected by
this oils all the rest of them he is
being shown to be superior amongst his
peers bring him back number five the
dream
here's another one that I oh I would
give almost anything for them to figure
out a way to bring him back
Toby Jones is just the perfect anti
doctor whereas the doctor as charm
he just has smarmy the doctor is this
ethical patron li figure he's just this
vicious little goblin and obviously
being a sort of an aspect of the dark
side of the doctor himself he knows the
doctor so well he was the companion so
well he knows how to mess with them how
to toy with them and he's just so sure
of himself he's just got this cockiness
wit and the doctors got a cockiness too
but the doctor has a cockiness that
makes you have confidence in him the
dream Lord has a cockiness that makes
you want to punch him it's the perfect
contrast number for the family of blood
I know on a number of these I said
they're ones I wish could come back I
would never bring these guys back
because they were so perfect with how
they were used don't bring them back
you're just gonna wreck it and I know we
even could because we know that with the
number of these characters they they
weren't they weren't killed the
daughter's sister one especially it's
even mentioned maybe one day the doctor
will let her out don't ever do that guys
please just let it end the way it did it
was so awesome this family and just the
way they relate to each other and how
they communicate it's just this slight
off-putting this how they don't have
names they only refer to each other by
what their relationship is mother of
mine sister of mine where the parents
call him son of mine and it's just it's
all about the family it's all about the
relationship you feel that bond between
them that they are so tightly knit and
yet so completely vicious they don't
care what is in their way they know what
they want and they are going to get it
no matter what they're straightforward
they're efficient but not in that sort
of cold cyber man on feeling way they've
got emotions they're emotionally
invested in what they're doing but
they're just so single-minded it's it's
frightening and the performance is by
all four of those actors are just so
perfect I would say it doesn't get much
better than that but I've got three
ranked above them so clearly it actually
gets a little better than that number
three the midnight entity we will
probably never know what that thing was
and what it was trying to do but you
know what it's better that way because
the
that we don't know what it was we don't
know what it wanted we don't know what
its ultimate goal was what it was
actually even really doing just makes it
that much more frightening just the idea
that there's this thing that could steal
not only your voice but the very essence
of you and it just takes it and claims
it for itself and it was so unnerving to
just watch the doctor try and be
compassionate and helpful and on an
understanding it didn't matter
it just didn't care no interest it just
wanted what he had and it was gonna take
it and it won now he did get saved by
that stewardess but he couldn't out talk
this thing he couldn't out think this
thing and it was so perfect to put that
in a later season like it's like a
season four so that we've gotten to know
the doctor you've got to know David
Tennant's doctor specifically we know he
can talk his way out of anything even if
he can't talk the villain Adak in it
killing him he can talk long enough that
he comes up with something else talking
in this case actually made it worse
because the more he talked the more
pulled from him it was a darn near
perfect villain for her character who
loves to talk number to the Beast what
can I say it's the devil I know that
they won't confirm that completely they
leave it a bit in Bay's of a cop it's
the devil and that should be really dumb
that should be really cheesy the devil
versus Doctor Who Oh what the heck is up
with that but the fact that they spread
it out over two parter so that it's not
a stupid cheesy gimmicky you get to know
this thing a bit and you get this really
hominis sense from it and that's just
based off the first episode before we
actually even get physical time with the
thing that voice and that just that
creature it's massiveness it's design
you just get raw power emanating from
this thing whether it's the voice or
it's the creature is those little looks
when it's possessing Toby
this thing is in
roll and to see the doctor get thrown
off that much just by conceptually what
it is he's facing that's really well
planned well paced intelligence
storytelling so who comes out on top who
can outdo the devil when it comes to
villains well for me there's just one
question that I got to ask you are you
my mummy the empty child oh my god this
thing freaked me out you need to
understand I love all these villains
whether it's the one off so the
recurring characters and so many of them
are really scary and I get that they are
scary like in concept I understand why
they're scary I understand how they're
scary
I don't actually get scared by them I'm
just not really person who gets scared
by entertainment as a general rule this
thing creeped me out though it was just
this sense that it didn't even really
know what it was doing or the damage
that it was causing and you kind of felt
bad for it especially as you learn more
about it and you realize this is just a
frightened child but it doesn't matter
because it can destroy you the idea of
something that innocent and that deadly
and happening the same physical being to
me is really telling terrifying I can't
not give this top spot to the one Doctor
Who film that has legitimately giving me
nightmares so there it is that is my
list of one-off Doctor Who villains top
10 for the modern era I'll be back to
talk recurring villains until that time
this council is adjourned